OK, everybody. Ready? Ready? Lights, camera, Christmas.
好了，各位。准备好了吗？准备好了吗？灯光、摄像，圣诞节开始了。
Well, my parents say that I can't have a dog.
嗯，我父母说我不能养狗。
This is Pirecua, age 11.
这是Pirecua，今年11岁。
So I wanted another animal that is, like, fuzzy, and it walks around.
所以我想要另一种动物，那种毛茸茸的，会到处走动的。
You know, I'm not really a pet sort of person. I think she knew she couldn't get a dog, basically.
你知道，我其实不太适合养宠物。我想她基本上知道自己养不了狗。
This is Linda, her mom. Linda is a reporter here at WBEZ, the station that our program comes from.
这是Linda，她的妈妈。Linda是WBEZ的一名记者，也就是我们这个节目所在的电台。
So a guinea pig was, I think, something she felt she could actually ask for. You know, that's the second place, I guess. It's still fuzzy and walks around.
所以我认为豚鼠是她觉得自己真正能开口要的东西。我想那是第二选择吧。它依然毛茸茸的，会到处走动。
Linda's husband is Mexican. And the kids lived in Mexico when they were smaller. So they don't write to Santa to ask for what they want. The Mexican tradition at Christmas is to write to the three kings.
Linda的丈夫是墨西哥人。孩子们小的时候住在墨西哥。所以他们不会写信给圣诞老人要礼物。墨西哥的圣诞传统是写信给三位国王。
So she wrote this letter to the three kings. And-- do you want me to read it?
所以她给三位国王写了这封信。而且——你想让我读一下吗？
Yeah, yeah. Could you read it?
好啊，好啊。你能读一下吗？
All right. It says, [SPEAKING SPANISH]. She says, like, dear three kings, I hope you're doing very well. I hope you're well.
好的。上面写着，[西班牙语]。她说，亲爱的三位国王，希望你们一切都好。希望你们安好。
I thought that was a nice touch.
我觉得这是一个很贴心的细节。
That is a nice touch.
那确实是个贴心的细节。
Yeah.
是啊。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]. She says, this year, I was thinking of asking for a guinea pig. And then she writes-- she has, like, an arrow. It's like an afterthought. She wrote, a real one. [SPANISH]. Then she goes on and asks for some other things. But what she really wanted-- I mean, has this whole list of things. But honestly, I don't ever remember her talking about anything else except the guinea pig.
[西班牙语]。她说，今年我本想要求一只豚鼠。然后她写道——她画了一个箭头。就像是事后想起来的一样。她写道，一只真的。 [西班牙语]。然后她继续要求了一些其他的东西。但她真正想要的——我的意思是，她列了一大堆愿望清单。但老实说，我不记得她谈论过除豚鼠以外的任何东西。
So, comes the big morning. This was two years ago. Pirecua was just nine. The three kings did, in fact, bring her a guinea pig. And, of course, she was thrilled. She named it Luna.
那么，那个盛大的早晨到来了。那是两年前。Pirecua当时才九岁。三位国王确实给她带来了一只豚鼠。当然，她非常兴奋。她给它取名叫Luna。
The guinea pig was in her arms, and it was running around her bed. And she was just in love. Well, that lasted about an hour before I just noticed she was scratching her forearms a lot.
豚鼠被抱在她怀里，在她的床上跑来跑去。她简直爱死它了。嗯，这种情况只持续了一个小时，我就注意到她一直在抓挠自己的前臂。
And she said that they were, like, hives. I was allergic to my guinea pig.
她说那是荨麻疹。我对我的豚鼠过敏。
She was completely scared that I would give the guinea pig away immediately. And I think her one goal was to keep the guinea pig. So she definitely did not complain about the hives.
她非常害怕我会立刻把豚鼠送走。我想她唯一的目标就是留下这只豚鼠。所以她绝对没有抱怨荨麻疹。
They were big red blotches, the size of silver dollars. Pirecua, however, would not be deterred.
那是大块红斑，有银元那么大。然而，Pirecua并没有退缩。
She still held it. She tried for a while. I was like, maybe if you cover yourself up. So what she started doing was she would put on this full face mask that she usually used on the coldest days in Chicago.
她依然抱着它。她尝试了一会儿。我说，也许你可以把自己遮住。于是她开始做的是戴上那种她通常在芝加哥最冷的日子里用的全脸面罩。
It was black. All you could see were her eyes. Linda showed me a photo of the full get up. You can see it on our website.
它是黑色的。你只能看到她的眼睛。Linda给我看了一张全副武装的照片。你们可以在我们的网站上看到。
She basically looks like a Zapatista rebel. She's got a long sleeve shirt. She's got her winter gloves on. And in the winter gloves, there's the little guinea pig peeking out from her hands.
她基本上看起来像个萨帕塔武装分子的反叛者。她穿着长袖衬衫，戴着冬天的手套。在那副手套里，露出一只小豚鼠，正从她的手中探出头来。
Meanwhile, paper towels stick out several inches from the gloves.
与此同时，纸巾从手套里伸出好几英寸。
So that there's absolutely no gap between her long-sleeve shirt and the gloves.
这样她的长袖衬衫和手套之间就完全没有空隙了。
She looks like a young terrorist.
她看起来像个年轻的恐怖分子。
With a cute guinea pig.
带着一只可爱的豚鼠。
With a cute guinea pig. Exactly. It looks like she's taken the guinea pig hostage or something.
带着一只可爱的豚鼠。没错。看起来她把豚鼠当作人质了还是什么的。
Pirecua is devoted to Luna, still. Lets it run around her room. Makes sure it's fed. In third grade, she had a photo of Luna that she pasted onto a little hand-drawn, cardboard frame with a little cardboard leg that she would prop up on her desk at the beginning of every school day facing her.
Pirecua至今仍对Luna忠心耿耿。让它在房间里跑来跑去，确保它吃饱。在三年级时，她有一张Luna的照片，贴在一个用硬纸板手工制作的小相框里，还装了一个小纸板支架，每天上学前她都把它摆在书桌上，正对着自己。
But it just feels a little weird, because she can't pick it up or hold it or even really pet it. So it's kind of like all the reasons you'd want a guinea pig, she can't have those.
但这种感觉有点奇怪，因为她不能抱起它、拿着它，甚至不能真正去抚摸它。所以，就像你想要豚鼠的所有理由，她都无法实现。
All a parent wants to do this time of year is make a nice Christmas for their kids. Linda does not even like pets, isn't crazy about having animals in the house. But the three kings brought a guinea pig, just like they brought her son something that she and her husband told him that they would never buy him themselves-- a video game system, a PlayStation 3.
每年这个时候，父母只想给孩子们过一个美好的圣诞节。Linda甚至不喜欢宠物，也不太乐意在家里养动物。但三位国王带来了一只豚鼠，就像他们给她儿子带了一些她和她丈夫告诉过他绝对不会自己买给他的东西——一个电子游戏机，PlayStation 3。
The three kings is-- they do test. They have tested me. They test parents, I think.
三位国王是——他们确实是在考验。他们考验过我。我想他们是在考验父母。
And not just parents. Linda asked Pirecua on tape, did the three kings know she was allergic when they brought her that gift? Pirecua told her she had never even considered the question.
而且不仅仅是父母。Linda在录音中问Pirecua，三位国王在带给她那个礼物时知道她过敏吗？Pirecua告诉她，她甚至从没考虑过这个问题。
But aren't they supposed to be [SPANISH], like wise men? Like, if they did know that you were going to be allergic to Luna, why do you think they still brought her for you?
但他们不是应该被称为[西班牙语]，像智者一样吗？如果他们确实知道你会对Luna过敏，你为什么认为他们还是把它带给了你？
Well, they would probably also know that I would love her even if I did have allergies.
嗯，他们可能也会知道，即使我有过敏症，我也会爱它。
And the three wise men made the right call.
三位智者做出了正确的选择。
Today on our radio program, in these last few frantic preparatory days before the holiday, we have stories of parents and others trying to make the holiday incredible for the people that they love, Going to great and ridiculous lengths involving live animals, a deer, a sled, ancient reindeer bones, which lead only sometimes to the most magical Christmases.
今天在我们的广播节目中，在节日前最后这几天忙乱的准备日子里，我们有父母和其他人试图为他们所爱的人创造不可思议的节日的各种故事。不惜代价，甚至采用荒诞的手段，涉及活体动物、鹿、雪橇、古老的驯鹿骨头，这些有时只会引向最神奇的圣诞节。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。请继续收听。
Act One, Christmas in 3D. We all learn at some point that our parents make mistakes. And that can even-- and I know this will be a shock-- make them when they are trying their hardest at Christmas. Maya Gurantz tells the story. A quick warning for people listening with young children, this is a story about one family's Santa Claus traditions, which may not be the same as yours. Here's Maya.
第一幕，3D圣诞节。我们最终都会发现父母也会犯错。甚至——我知道这会让人震惊——当他们在圣诞节尽最大努力时，也会犯错。Maya Gurantz讲述了这个故事。给有年幼孩子收听的家庭提个醒，这是一个关于一个家庭圣诞老人传统的故事，可能和你家的不一样。这是Maya带来的报道。
My friend, Colin Mutchler, is 36. And to this day, he talks about his Christmases as a kid. That's because his parents were determined to make the magic of Christmas come alive for their three kids, Colin, Adam, and Erica.
我的朋友Colin Mutchler今年36岁。至今他还在谈论他小时候的圣诞节。那是因为他的父母决心为他们的三个孩子——Colin、Adam和Erica——让圣诞魔法成真。
But they went further than any parents I know. They wanted it to be real-- really real. This wasn't an airbrushed, ho, ho, ho Christmas, but a darker, grittier one. Like that one year when Colin was seven and his dad sent him to the garage for some firewood.
但他们比我认识的任何父母走得都远。他们希望那是真实的——非常真实。这不是那种精修过的、只会喊“嚯嚯嚯”的圣诞节，而是一个更黑暗、更粗犷的圣诞节。就像Colin七岁那年，他爸爸让他去车库取些柴火。
And I heard some bells. And it kind of freaked me out. And so I ran inside, and I was like, oh my god, you guys. I swear I heard some bells. And my dad was like, no way. Really? And so we went back slowly outside. And basically, we found this older man.
我听到了一些铃声。这让我有点害怕。所以我跑进屋里，我说，噢天哪，你们听着。我发誓我听到了铃声。我爸爸说，不可能。真的吗？于是我们慢慢回到外面。基本上，我们发现了一个老人。
Colin's younger brother Adam was there too.
Colin的弟弟Adam当时也在那里。
This man had fallen in the backyard and slipped on the ice. I was so young that it was like, who is this crazy man in our backyard? And I sort of, are you OK? Are you OK? And they brought him inside.
这个人在后院摔倒了，在冰上滑了一跤。我太小了，感觉就像，这个在我们后院的疯老头是谁？我稍微问了问，你没事吧？你还好吗？他们把他带进屋里。
He was wearing a very old, rundown, weathered jacket. He said he had windburn.
他穿着一件非常旧、破损、风化的夹克。他说他被风吹伤了。
And could you dim the lights? I've got snow blindness, you know, from the time in the North Pole. And there's a certain amount of glare that I can't deal with. So we dim the lights.
能把灯光调暗点吗？我得了雪盲症，你知道，在北极待过的时间太长了。有一种特定的强光我受不了。所以我们调暗了灯光。
He talked in a very soft-spoken-- not a whisper but where he talked quietly enough that the whole room was silent, and you had to kind of lean in. And it was that sort of weird, intimate sort of-- you're just immersed in whatever he was saying. And he basically said, I'm Kris Kringle.
他说话的声音非常轻柔——不是耳语，但确实轻到整个房间都安静下来，你不得不凑过去听。那是一种奇怪的、亲密的氛围——你完全沉浸在他所说的任何事情中。他基本上说，我是克里斯·克林格（Kris Kringle）。
Adam was four. And he says this is his earliest memory of Christmas. All the Mutchler kids have memories like this, probably because they talked about it all the time when they were little. Colin and Adam didn't think there was just one Santa Claus living at the North Pole.
Adam当时四岁。他说这是他关于圣诞节最早的记忆。所有的Mutchler家孩子都有这样的记忆，可能是因为他们小时候一直谈论这件事。Colin和Adam不认为世界上只有一个住在北极的圣诞老人。
The Mutchler family had their own mythology with its own logic. There wasn't just one Santa but a network of Santas all working together as Christmas helpers. Kris Kringle was just one of them, a working man's Santa. And just like a guy on a night shift from hell, he was exhausted.
Mutchler家族有他们自己的神话体系和逻辑。不仅有一个圣诞老人，而是一个作为圣诞助手的圣诞老人网络。克里斯·克林格只是其中之一，一个劳碌命的圣诞老人。就像一个从地狱班次上下来的家伙，他筋疲力尽。
We kind of were almost helping him. The dynamic was such that it was like he was in a rough place, and we were trying to help him. And so I think we talked with him for a bit and then put him on his way.
我们当时几乎是在帮助他。这种动态就是他处境艰难，而我们试图帮助他。我想我们和他谈了一会儿，然后送他上路了。
Visitors like Kris appeared every couple of years or so in the band of woods dividing their house in Harrington Park, New Jersey from a nearby golf course. Never the same guy, never in exactly the same place. They'd be disheveled, bearded and hoarse-voiced, abandoned by their skittish and surprisingly losable reindeer, and searching for the Mutchlers, whose home address they never quite figured out.
像克里斯这样的访客每隔几年就会出现在他们新泽西州哈灵顿公园的家与附近高尔夫球场之间的树林里。从不是同一个人，也从不在同一个地方。他们总是衣衫褴褛、胡子拉碴、嗓音嘶哑，被他们那些胆小且出奇容易走丢的驯鹿抛弃，一直在寻找Mutchler家，但始终没搞清楚他们的确切地址。
The Mutchlers also had a family elf, Jeko, who the kids never saw, but who apparently lived in the attic for a few weeks before Christmas. The kids would hear noises coming from upstairs-- hammering, walking. And when Christmas was over, they'd find wood scraps in the attic from the gifts he'd made for them, proof that Jeko had been there.
Mutchler家还有一个家庭精灵，Jeko。孩子们从没见过他，但他显然在圣诞节前几周住在阁楼里。孩子们会听到楼上传来的声音——敲击声、走动声。当圣诞节结束后，他们会在阁楼里找到他为他们制作礼物时留下的木屑，证明Jeko曾经来过。
Both their father and grandfather grew up with Jeko. Their grandfather, especially, loved to tell scary stories about how mean Jeko could be. And so every Christmas, the family spent hours combing over the details of Jeko and their visitors, comparing them to previous Christmases, anticipating the next.
他们的父亲和祖父都是伴随着Jeko长大的。尤其是他们的祖父，特别喜欢讲恐怖故事，说Jeko有多刻薄。所以每年圣诞节，家人都要花上几个小时研究Jeko和这些访客的细节，将他们与往年的圣诞节进行比较，并期待下一个。
When you ask the Mutchler kids which Christmas visitor was the one who outdid the rest, there's no question. Christmas Eve 1984. Colin was eight. Adam was five. Erica was two. The family was out taking their usual walk. And on this night they went down to the golf course. It was foggy and dark. Here's Adam.
当你问Mutchler家的孩子们哪一个圣诞访客最让人难忘时，答案是毫无疑问的。1984年平安夜。Colin八岁，Adam五岁，Erica两岁。全家出去散步。那天晚上他们去了高尔夫球场。天黑雾浓。这是Adam的讲述。
And then in the distance, we see this silhouette of a shadow scampering from tree to tree-- and it's a golf course, so it's open, wide spaces-- and looking like they don't want us to know that they're there. And my dad says, lets go find out who that is. As so we start walking faster to try to catch up with this guy.
然后在远处，我们看到了一个身影在树与树之间窜动——那是高尔夫球场，所以很开阔——看起来他们不想让我们知道他们在那里。我爸爸说，我们去看看那是谁。于是我们加快脚步试图追上那个家伙。
When we come upon him, he's in this very worn, dirty Santa Claus suit that's kind of this greenish brown tint. And he introduces himself as Klaus Hoffer. And he's one of many sort of the Santa Claus incarnations. And I don't know if he goes into a full explanation, but he definitely explains that-- I think we mentioned Kris Kringle. And it's like, oh yeah, I know Kris.
当我们追上他时，他穿着一件非常破旧、肮脏的圣诞老人服，颜色呈青褐色。他自我介绍说他是克劳斯·霍弗（Klaus Hoffer）。他是众多圣诞老人化身中的一个。我不记得他是否给出了完整的解释，但他确实解释说——我想我们提到了克里斯·克林格。他说，哦对，我认识克里斯。
Klaus had a worn sack and began pulling out presents.
克劳斯带着一个破旧的袋子，开始掏出礼物。
But the presents were very odd. There was vegetables, a head of broccoli, an onion. And then he also, I think, gave us some bones. And that sort of comes to the most important thing is he broke out one bone in particular. And he said, this is one of the bones from the original Rudolph. I use it to call the reindeer.
但礼物非常奇怪。有蔬菜，一颗西兰花，一个洋葱。然后我想，他还给了我们一些骨头。最重要的事情是他拿出了特别的一根骨头。他说，这是原始鲁道夫（红鼻子驯鹿）的骨头之一。我用它来召唤驯鹿。
Again, here's Colin and their sister, Erica.
再次请出Colin和他们的妹妹Erica。
And literally when he broke out bones and started blowing on them, we were like, oh my god. This is crazy.
当他拿出骨头开始吹奏时，我们简直惊呆了，噢天哪。这太疯狂了。
It made no noise. We couldn't hear it. But he said it was a pitch that only the reindeer could hear.
它没有任何声音。我们听不见。但他说是只有驯鹿才能听到的音调。
And when he talked about Rudolph, it wasn't like, (SINGING) Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer. It was like he kind of was honoring the history of Rudolph as some reindeer that they all honored. And the fact that he had some of these bones of Rudolph and was using them to call to the reindeer just-- it made sense to us. It was like, that makes sense.
当他谈论鲁道夫时，不像唱（唱歌）《红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫》。他像是在以此缅怀鲁道夫的历史，作为他们所有驯鹿都尊敬的一员。而且他拥有鲁道夫的骨头并用它来召唤驯鹿的事实——这对我们来说很有道理。就像，这说得通。
The details were perfectly calibrated, as only people who know you as well as your parents can get just right. Here's Adam.
细节调整得非常完美，只有像父母那样了解你的人才能做得恰到好处。这是Adam的讲述。
And that's when it got kind of scary. He offered all of the kids. And he said, I can only invite the kids. But do you guys want to come on the sleigh? Do you want to come to the North Pole with me? And we just sat there, frozen. Wow. I could say yes.
然后事情变得有点吓人了。他向所有的孩子发出邀请。他说，我只能邀请孩子们。但你们想坐雪橇吗？你们想跟我一起去北极吗？我们只是坐在那里，惊呆了。哇。我可以答应。
The answer is no. The truth is when some old man that you just met in the dark golf course on Christmas Eve actually asks me and my brother and my sister if we want to go with him somewhere that we have no idea, while that might be the coolest thing of all time, it might also be the end of life as I know it.
答案是不。事实上，当一个你在平安夜的漆黑高尔夫球场上刚遇到的老头，真的问我和我的弟妹是否想和他去一个我们完全不知道的地方时，虽然那可能是史上最酷的事情，但也可能是终结我已知生活的开始。
Again Erica, who, remember, was two at the time.
再次请出Erica，记住，她当时只有两岁。
I remember screaming and not wanting to go. I was just terrified.
我记得自己在尖叫，不想去。我当时简直吓坏了。
Actually, that invitation to the North Pole, that never happened-- at least not the way they remember it.
其实，那个去北极的邀请，从来没有发生过——至少不像他们记忆中那样。
Klaus.
克劳斯。
Yeah, yeah, Klaus.
对，对，克劳斯。
Klaus.
克劳斯。
This is a recording from that Christmas Eve in 1984. Erica, Adam, and Colin had just come back from meeting Klaus. On the recording, the kids seem happy and hopped up on adrenalin. They talk about Klaus but in the entire recording never mention any invitation to the North Pole. What you hear instead is the grandfather suggesting, how would you like it if he had asked you to the North Pole? Then their father, Glenn, jumps in.
这是一段1984年平安夜的录音。Erica、Adam和Colin刚从见到克劳斯的路上回来。录音中，孩子们看起来很高兴，肾上腺素飙升。他们谈论着克劳斯，但在整段录音中从未提到过任何关于去北极的邀请。你听到的是祖父建议说，如果他邀请你们去北极，你们会喜欢吗？然后他们的父亲Glenn插话了。
Look, you guys could have asked, and he would have taken you. I had a feeling he would be willing to take somebody for a short trip.
看，你们本来可以要求去，他会带你们去的。我有种预感，他很乐意带人进行短途旅行。
They were scared.
他们当时很害怕。
I was scared, too.
我也很害怕。
Behold, the power of suggestion. That's how it seemed like a lot of it worked-- the Mutchler parents making suggestions and adding details and then retelling it all year after year. Christmas was a big topic of conversation, and the Mutchler parents encouraged their kids with the most exciting versions of what happened on those nights, to the point where the stories gained an unstoppable momentum.
看，这就是暗示的力量。看起来很多事情都是这样运作的——Mutchler夫妇给出暗示，添加细节，然后年复一年地复述。圣诞节是一个很大的话题，父母用最令人兴奋的版本来鼓励孩子们，以至于这些故事产生了不可阻挡的动能。
As the Mutchler kids got older, things, as they do, changed. Each of the kids dealt with it differently. Both Colin and Erica say they knew at a certain point to not talk about Jeko and the others to people outside their closest circles.
随着孩子们长大，事情也发生了变化。每个孩子处理的方式不同。Colin和Erica说，他们在某个时候知道不能在圈外人面前谈论Jeko和其他人。
But Adam didn't get that-- at all. Adam loved to tell a good story. He couldn't not tell this one. And he believed wholeheartedly in his experiences-- even as a teenager, in public school, in New Jersey. And it had consequences.
但Adam完全没领会这一点。Adam喜欢讲好故事。他忍不住不说这个。而且他全心全意地相信他的经历——即使在青春期，在新泽西州的公立学校也是如此。这造成了后果。
When Adam was in fifth grade, he defended his stories about Klaus and Kris and the rest in front of his whole class. It got so confrontational, with Adam telling the whole group how wrong they were, that the teacher ended up calling Adam's parents, telling them it had almost started a fight, and asking them to please tell Adam to stop talking about it.
Adam五年级时，当着全班同学的面为他关于克劳斯、克里斯等人的故事辩护。事情变得非常具有对抗性，Adam告诉全班同学他们错了，最后老师给Adam的父母打了电话，说这差点引发了一场打架，要求他们告诉Adam不要再谈论这件事了。
Adam remembers many arguments like this well into middle school. People would call him an idiot or weird. And he would insist that these events were true. He was there. It was real. You guys are crazy, not me.
Adam记得中学时期有很多这样的争论。人们叫他傻瓜或怪胎。但他坚持认为这些事情是真的。他在现场。那是真实的。你们才疯了，不是我。
The next year, sixth grade, Adam was at his grandparents' house at Christmastime when his great aunt Blanche made some offhanded comment about which uncle played what part what year back when they were kids. Adam walked himself through the logic of what she was saying. And he knew right then that his parents had lied to him.
第二年，六年级，Adam在圣诞节期间在他祖父母家，他的姑婆Blanche随口评论了一句哪位叔叔哪一年扮演了什么角色。Adam理清了她所说的话的逻辑。他当时就知道他的父母对他撒了谎。
Not only did they lie to me. It was, you know, 13 years old. I had to deal with that as a social thing that I had done. I had defended myself and told these stories.
他们不仅对我撒谎。当时我13岁。我不得不把它当作一件我做过的社交事件来处理。我为自己辩护过，讲过这些故事。
In front of lots of people.
当着很多人的面。
Lots of people. And to know that my parents were sort of responsible for allowing me to perpetuate something that made me a liar and a laughingstock.
很多人。想到我的父母竟然允许我延续这种让我变成骗子和笑柄的事情，这真让人受不了。
You were embarrassed.
你感到尴尬。
I was very embarrassed.
我非常尴尬。
Adam felt betrayed and was angry about it for years. One year, he came home from college and accused his parents for being the reason he couldn't trust anyone enough to have a serious girlfriend. Not too different from the sorts of speeches lots of kids make to their parents at that age. Except it was about Santa. Even he admits it was pretty extreme.
Adam感到被背叛了，并且为此愤怒了多年。有一年，他从大学回家，指责父母是他无法信任任何人以至于无法拥有一段严肃恋情的原因。这和许多孩子在那个年纪对父母所作的演讲没什么两样。除了那是关于圣诞老人的。即使他也承认这有点极端。
So this one thing made you feel like you couldn't trust your parents, even though they were trustworthy parents.
所以这一件事让你觉得无法信任你的父母，尽管他们是值得信赖的父母。
Well, for me, it was the intricacy and the planning of, like, you spent 7 years or 10 years perpetrating a lie that was so deep and complex. Like whether it was hiring people, vintage suits, hunting people through the golf course and through the woods. What are you, insane? Like, this is diabolical. For me, there was a big breakdown in the way I trusted people in my life that actually, I think it carried on into my adult life. And even to this day, I don't 100% trust anyone anymore.
嗯，对我来说，这是一种复杂性和策划，你花了7年或10年去编造一个如此深刻而复杂的谎言。比如聘请人、穿上旧式服装、在高尔夫球场和树林里搜寻人。你们是疯了吗？这简直太邪恶了。对我来说，我信任人的方式发生了巨大的崩溃，我觉得这甚至延续到了我的成年生活中。直到今天，我仍然不能100%信任任何人。
Do you feel like it made you cynical?
你觉得这让你变得愤世嫉俗了吗？
A little bit. Yeah, a little bit.
有一点。是的，有一点。
Adam's 33 and can laugh about most of this now. He sees what was great about what his parents did at Christmas. But he won't be doing anything like it, he says, when he has his own kids. And because of the way he reacted as a teenager, these childhood Christmases are still a touchy subject in this family. When they talk about it, everybody's careful to keep things upbeat. I wondered if the parents had any regrets for how they handled it. So I went to meet the Mutchlers.
Adam现在33岁了，对这一切大多能付之一笑。他看到了父母在圣诞节所做事情的美好之处。但他说，当他有自己的孩子时，他不会做任何类似的事情。由于他青春期的反应，这些童年的圣诞节在这个家庭里仍然是一个敏感话题。当谈论这个时，每个人都很谨慎地保持乐观。我想知道父母对于他们处理这件事的方式是否有任何遗憾。所以我去见了Mutchler夫妇。
Oh, you know my two boys.
噢，你认识我的两个男孩。
I do, I do.
是的，是的。
Glenn and Laurie Mutchler live on a beautiful, quiet street. It's the kind of place where deer wander through the yards. A giant wreath hangs off the top the Mutchlers' beige clapboard house. Christmas lights twinkle inside and outside. We sit in the living room, where the mantle has been turned into an altar crowded with an assortment of spiritual icons-- Buddhas, Vishnu, a ceramic bust of Jesus, and two different portraits of Jerry Garcia.
Glenn和Laurie Mutchler住在一个美丽、安静的街道上。那是个鹿会在院子里漫步的地方。一个巨大的花环挂在Mutchler家米色挂板房子的顶部。圣诞彩灯在室内和室外闪烁。我们坐在客厅里，壁炉架被改造成了一个挤满了各种精神偶像的祭坛——佛像、毗湿奴、耶稣的陶瓷半身像，以及两幅不同的Jerry Garcia画像。
I was a hippie and did the whole nine yards, Glenn told me, on the West Coast in the '70s. Though he doesn't like the word hippie-- thinks it's come to connote laziness, and he's anything but. We started talking about the elaborate Christmases the Mutchlers used to have for their kids. And I asked Laurie.
Glenn告诉我，我在70年代的西海岸是个嬉皮士，做了所有那种事。虽然他不喜欢“嬉皮士”这个词——认为它现在暗示懒惰，而他绝非如此。我们开始谈论Mutchler家过去为孩子们举办的精致圣诞节。我问Laurie。
How did you get roped into all of this?
你们是怎么被卷入这一切的？
Well, I-- as we were talking about this--
嗯，我——当我们谈论这个时——
That's the cynic.
这就是那个愤世嫉俗者。
I am going to talk now.
我现在要说话了。
Listen to this.
听着这个。
No, no, no. I want to talk.
不，不，不。我想说。
Roped in.
被卷入。
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
I don't know if you caught that, but he called me a cynic.
我不知道你是否注意到了，但他叫我愤世嫉俗者。
You know, I'm not a cynic. We're just so excited about how you pulled this off.
你知道，我不是愤世嫉俗者。我们只是对你们是如何成功实现这一切感到兴奋。
There is no pulling off. Something happened. People had an experience. And then you have this thought called, somebody pulled something off.
根本没有所谓的实现。事情发生了。人们有了这种体验。然后你产生了这种叫“有人搞了什么把戏”的想法。
I wasn't prepared for this. Decades after these Christmases, Glenn was refusing to admit he had anything to do with creating them.
我没准备好迎接这个。在这些圣诞节过去几十年后，Glenn拒绝承认他与创造这一切有任何关系。
So the conjecture and all that stuff would really undermine the magic. In fact, all the details, as you called them, the mechanics, or as you put, how'd you pull it off? It happened. That's the magic, and that's the secret.
所以推测和所有这些东西真的会破坏魔法。事实上，正如你所说的所有细节，那种机制，或者如你所说，你是怎么搞成的？它发生了。这就是魔法，这就是秘密。
We went back and forth about this for more than 10 minutes. Here's my producer, Robyn, having a go at it.
我们在这件事上反复讨论了10多分钟。这是我的制片人Robyn在尝试询问。
It would help to know if that's just, like, an impossible thing for us ask. Because we have some questions about how it works. And I just-- I'm wondering if we could--
如果我们知道这是否是一个我们无法询问的问题会有帮助。因为我们对它是如何运作的有一些疑问。我只是——我在想我们能不能——
You could make something up. You could hypothesize. But that's you. Because the magic's too powerful.
你可以编造一些东西。你可以假设。但那是你。因为魔法太强大了。
And did they have any regrets about when their kids learned the truth? I asked Glenn and Laurie about the time that Adam fought with his fifth grade class about the Mutchler Christmas stories. It seemed like it would have been a perfect moment to come clean.
他们对孩子们得知真相的时候有任何遗憾吗？我问Glenn和Laurie关于Adam为了Mutchler圣诞故事与五年级同学争吵的那次。那似乎是一个彻底坦白的好时机。
They said after the school called them, they did talk to Adam. But they didn't tell him he was wrong. They didn't tell him the truth. If anything, they encouraged him to believe the stories were real, saying, I was there. You were there. Their only parental advice was, be more private about it. Stop talking about it at school. Though Laurie did come to worry that they should have handled it differently.
他们说在学校给他们打电话后，他们确实和Adam谈过。但他们没有告诉他他错了。他们没有告诉他真相。如果有的话，他们鼓励他相信这些故事是真的，说，我当时在现场。你也在现场。他们唯一的父母建议是，这件事要低调点。不要再在学校谈论它了。尽管Laurie确实开始担心他们是否应该采取不同的处理方式。
I think for me, I did really start to question whether we should be making such a big deal about it. And I wanted to stop doing it. It definitely happened in my mind. I did. And as you can tell, Glenn's a very powerful force in our family. Yeah, he is. And even before this interview, it was sort of like, you set up the ground rules about how we were going to have the interview. They're going to ask us, and we're not going to tell, right?
我想对我来说，我确实开始质疑我们是否应该对此大惊小怪。我确实想停止这样做。在我的脑海里确实发生过。是的。如你所见，Glenn在我们家里是一个非常强大的力量。是的，他确实是。甚至在这次采访之前，这就有点像是，你制定了我们将如何进行采访的基本规则。他们会问我们，我们不会说，对吧？
Both Glenn and Laurie say they tried to make it right for Adam. They had no idea how betrayed he felt until later. Laurie says for a while, she didn't know what to do.
Glenn和Laurie都说他们试图为Adam弥补这一切。他们根本不知道他感到被背叛了，直到后来。Laurie说有一段时间，她不知道该怎么办。
We talked about it a lot. We talked about the magic and the wanting it to-- Adam can you see? Can you find a place where you see where it all came from? It all came from good. It didn't come from lying. It didn't come from tricking. We are not bad parents because we did that.
我们讨论了很多。我们谈论了魔法以及希望它——Adam你能看出来吗？你能找到一个你能看出这一切来自哪里的地方吗？这一切都源于善良。它不是源于撒谎。不是源于欺骗。我们不是坏父母，因为我们那样做了。
Finally, Laurie tells me this story. It's an important one for her. And before she starts, she says she knows Glenn doesn't want her to tell it. But that's not going to stop her. One Christmas Eve, when Adam was in junior high school, Laurie went to his bedroom.
最后，Laurie告诉了我这个故事。这对她来说很重要。在开始之前，她说她知道Glenn不想让她讲。但这阻止不了她。一个平安夜，当Adam在上初中时，Laurie去了他的卧室。
And I was giving him a good night kiss and hug and Merry Christmas. And he looked me straight in the eyes, and he said, you've got to tell me the truth. Your son is looking you right in the eyes saying, you've got to tell me the truth. Were those real? Did Santa really visit us?
我给了他晚安吻和拥抱，祝他圣诞快乐。他直视我的眼睛，说，你必须告诉我真相。你的儿子正盯着你的眼睛说，你必须告诉我真相。那是真的吗？圣诞老人真的来看过我们吗？
And in the back of my mind, it was Glenn's voice going, you never tell. You never tell. The magic, the magic. And I spewed all this magic. And it's the magic. And it's the spirit. And I went on and on. And he would not let it down. He just said, stop it. Don't talk about that stuff. Glenn talks about that stuff. You'll tell me the truth. Tell me the truth.
而在我的脑海深处，是Glenn的声音在回响，你绝不能说。你绝不能说。魔法，魔法。我就喷涌出了所有这些魔法的话语。这都是魔法。这是精神。我没完没了地说。他就是不肯放过。他只是说，停下来。不要谈论那些东西。Glenn才谈论那些东西。你要告诉我真相。告诉我真相。
And I don't even know what I exactly said. But I did let him know that it wasn't real. And we just cried, the two of us. And it was really sad. Because then over the years, when he did say later-- when he said, I can't believe that that was a parenting decision that you made, that you went to that extreme-- it just hurt him.
我甚至不知道我具体说了什么。但我确实让他知道那不是真的。我们俩都哭了。那真的很悲伤。因为后来几年，当他确实说——当他说，我无法相信那是你们做出的养育决定，你们竟然走到了那一步——这真的伤害了他。
And it was so weird, because Colin and Erica had taken the same wonderful experience and held it as a wonderful experience. No matter what happened or what was real, they could hold it as just a magical, wonderful moment. And he somehow couldn't. And it made me really sad.
这真的很奇怪，因为Colin和Erica拥有了同样的奇妙体验，并将其作为一种美好的经历保留了下来。无论发生了什么或什么才是真实的，他们都能将其视为一个奇妙、美好的时刻。而他不知何故做不到。这让我感到非常悲伤。
Glenn understands that something went wrong with Adam.
Glenn明白Adam身上出了点问题。
My experience is like this with kids. You do the best you can. And sometimes you do the right thing. And maybe you do the wrong thing when you thought you did the right thing. There's a time when the kids are young and you experience the magic through them. And it's just so special to be around young kids. And to be in that-- maybe you cheat a little bit, and you sort of become-- you're living through them.
我的经验是关于孩子这样的。你尽你所能。有时你做对了事。有时你以为做了对的事，结果却做错了。孩子小的时候，你会通过他们体验到魔法。和年幼的孩子在一起真是太特别了。那种——也许你作弊了一点，你变得——你在通过他们生活。
Glenn had been eager from the moment we arrived at his house to take us on a tour of Christmas past. And after our interview, Glenn and Laurie head out with us for a walk. We go up the street, pass through some trees, and onto the golf course.
从我们到达他家那一刻起，Glenn就渴望带我们回顾过去的圣诞节。采访结束后，Glenn和Laurie带着我们出去散步。我们走上街道，穿过一些树木，来到高尔夫球场。
It was darker than I had imagined it would be, barely illuminated by the ambient orange of nearby streetlights. Mist clung to the rolling expanse of grass. Then Glenn does what he's clearly been itching to do all night-- gives us the play-by-play from his finest hour, the night Klaus Hoffer came to visit.
那里比我想象的要黑，几乎被附近路灯发出的橙色微光照亮。薄雾笼罩着起伏的草地。然后Glenn做了他整晚显然都在渴望做的事情——为我们重演了他最精彩的时刻，克劳斯·霍弗来访的那个晚上。
Get away. Stay away. Who-- who is it? I'm looking for the Mucklers. And then the kids said, no, the Mutchlers?
走开。离远点。谁——是谁？我在找Mutchler家。然后孩子们说，不，是Mutchler家吗？
Glenn hunches down and reenacts Klaus Hoffer's disappearance into the distance.
Glenn弓下身子，重现了克劳斯·霍弗消失在远处的场景。
You know, like, kind of like this.
你知道，就像，有点像这样。
He lopes along. He's happy. Magic is Glenn's strength and his blind spot.
他轻快地走着。他很开心。魔法是Glenn的强项，也是他的盲点。
We're all standing there going, oh my god. Did that really happen? It was like that. It was perfect. It was perfect.
我们都站在那里说，噢天哪。那真的发生过吗？就像那样。太完美了。简直完美。
Maya Gurantz in Los Angeles. Coming up, typecast. Typecast-- do you hear me-- as a reindeer in a Christmas pageant. The tail-twitching injustice of it. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
Maya Gurantz在洛杉矶。接下来，定型。定型——你听到了吗——在圣诞游行中扮演驯鹿。那种摇尾巴的不公。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show for the holidays, "Lights, Camera, Christmas." Stories of people trying to throw a nice Christmas for those they love. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Deer in the Footlights. So Connie grew up on this ranch outside of a little town in Utah called Woodruff. And maybe you've never been to Woodruff.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周我们的节目，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的不同种类的故事。今天关于节日的节目，“灯光、摄像、圣诞节”。人们试图为他们所爱的人举办一个美好圣诞节的故事。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，灯光下的鹿。Connie是在犹他州Woodruff小镇外的一个牧场长大的。也许你从来没去过Woodruff。
It's-- let me tell you about it. You'll have to edit this now, because I'm going to say it like I always say it.
它——让我告诉你吧。你现在得编辑一下，因为我要像我平时说的那样说它。
OK.
好的。
You go through town. There's a church on the right. There's an old school on the left. You get down to the crossroads, and there's a half-assed store on one side and the post office on the other side.
你穿过小镇。右边有一座教堂。左边有一所旧学校。你到达十字路口，一边有一家半吊子的商店，另一边是邮局。
That's it, the whole town. Maybe 250 people, she says, maybe fewer. And the basic facts of her childhood are the kinds of things that lots of little girls only read about in story books. During the summer, Connie and her two sisters, they would get up. They'd have some food. And they would spend the whole day, she says, on their own horses, riding far and wide together.
就是这样，整个镇子。她说，也许250人，也许更少。她童年的基本事实是许多小女孩只在故事书里读到的那种事。夏天，Connie和她的两个姐妹起床。吃点东西。然后她们会花一整天时间，她说，骑着她们自己的马，一起走得很远。
And when they were little, they got a baby deer-- a baby deer of their very own-- who ended up a part of Christmas at their elementary school in a way that, I think, probably very rarely happens with deers and elementary schools and Christmases.
当她们小的时候，她们得到了一只小鹿——一只她们自己心爱的小鹿——后来它以一种我认为在鹿、小学和圣诞节之间很少发生的方式参与了她们小学的圣诞游行。
So the story that I want you to tell us, I want to know how a deer ended up on the stage as part of your school's Christmas pageant when you were a kid. And I guess you should explain how you even ended up with a deer in the first place. Do you remember when you first saw the deer?
所以我想让你讲的故事是，我想知道当你还是个孩子的时候，一只鹿是如何在舞台上成为你学校圣诞游行的一部分的。我想你应该解释一下你们是怎么得到那只鹿的。你记得你第一次见到那只鹿的时候吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah. We were all on our horses. And there was a doe that had just had a baby. It was, I'd say, maybe two or three days old. Well, we chased the doe off and took the deer-- took the fawn.
噢，是的。是的。我们都骑着马。有一只母鹿刚刚生了宝宝。我想，它可能才两三天大。嗯，我们把母鹿赶走，然后带走了这只鹿——带走了小鹿。
Did you run off the mom hoping to get the baby?
你为了得到宝宝把妈妈赶走了？
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
You did.
你是这么做的。
Oh, yeah. And brought it home. Let me tell you what. We never done it again, because my dad was really pissed, just livid. He lit into us like you can't believe.
噢，是的。然后把它带回家。让我告诉你吧。我们再也没做过这种事，因为我爸爸气坏了，简直暴跳如雷。他像你无法想象的那样教训了我们。
And what was his argument? What was the problem with bringing in this deer?
他的论点是什么？带回这只鹿有什么问题？
Nature should be left to nature. Why did we want to run that deer off, that mother, when she was perfectly capable of raising this fawn and taking care of it? Why did we-- what give us the right to do with it, to take Mother Nature's course away from them?
大自然应该顺其自然。为什么我们要把那只母鹿赶走，当她完全有能力抚养这只小鹿并照顾它的时候？我们为什么要——什么权利给了我们把它们从大自然的规律中夺走的资格？
How big is a fawn when it's that little? It is the size of a big dog? I'm trying to picture.
小鹿那么小时有多大？它像大狗那么大吗？我在试图想象。
Yeah. It would be about the size of the big dog, maybe not a real big dog. And they're light. It couldn't have weighed any more than, I'm going to say 25, 35 pounds. And we put it on our horses, put it across the saddle and packed it back to the house. Oh, we was tickled. We really thought we'd done something good.
是的。大约是大狗的大小，也许不是那种非常大的狗。而且它们很轻。它的重量不可能超过，我说是25到35磅。我们把它放在马上，跨在马鞍上带回了家。噢，我们当时高兴极了。我们真的觉得我们做了一件好事。
And so you raised it. How do you feed it?
所以你们抚养了它。你们怎么喂它？
You put a lamb nipple on the end of a pop bottle, and they suck it. And so we raised him that summer. And then, of course, he lost his spots.
你在汽水瓶口装上羊奶嘴，它们就会吸吮。所以那个夏天我们把它养大了。然后，当然，它身上的斑点消失了。
Did you give it a name?
你们给它取名字了吗？
Well, we called him Bambi.
嗯，我们叫它Bambi。
Very original. OK.
很有创意。好的。
Yeah, very original.
是的，很有创意。
So was he a good pet?
那它是一只好的宠物吗？
Oh, yeah, yeah. He was a lot of fun. We never had a collar or anything on him. Never did break him to lead. We just put our hands on his, what we call their withers, where their neck goes right into their shoulders. And he'd walk by you. So we could walk him. Damn near any place we wanted to go, he'd go.
噢，是的，是的。它非常有意思。我们从来没给它戴过项圈什么的。也没训练它领路。我们只是把手放在它所谓的肩胛骨上，也就是脖子和肩膀交界的地方。它就会在你身边走。所以我们可以牵着它走。几乎我们想去的任何地方，它都会跟着。
So that year, the year we got him, that was the year that they done the play. And they took a balloon and blew it up about the size of a golf ball and put it on his nose. And he stood there with this red thing on his nose all during the play. And if I remember right, the story just more or less centered around Santa Claus being sad because he couldn't get around.
那一年，也就是我们得到它的那一年，就是他们排演那场剧的那一年。他们拿了一个气球，吹到高尔夫球大小，放在它的鼻子上。在那场剧中，它一直站在那里，鼻子上顶着那个红色的东西。如果我没记错的话，故事差不多就是围绕着圣诞老人因为无法走动而感到悲伤展开的。
Well, it sounds like "Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer," where his nose is what guides them. The light from his nose is what guides them to where they need to go.
嗯，这听起来像是《红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫》，它的鼻子是引导他们的东西。它鼻子的光引导他们去需要去的地方。
I think so. I think that's what it was. I can remember that the hall was just crowded. Everybody knew that deer was going to be in there. And so everybody come to watch it.
我想是这样。我想那应该就是那样。我记得大厅里挤满了人。大家都知道那只鹿会出现在那里。所以大家都来看它。
Oh, really? He was the star attraction of the show? He brought the crowd?
噢，真的吗？它是演出的明星吗？它带来了观众？
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. They still talk about that play. I don't think they ever did top that play. How could you?
噢，是的。噢，是的。他们至今还在谈论那场戏。我觉得他们再也没超越过那场戏。怎么可能超越呢？
Was he on stage for most of the show?
它在舞台上待了大部分时间吗？
Oh, he was on stage for the whole show. He probably stood there for a good two hours. So we spent the whole night standing there by the deer. He'd look out in the crowd and look everybody over. You could see his ears moving back and forth. But we'd pet him or scratch him on the neck.
噢，它在舞台上待了整场演出。它大概站了整整两个小时。所以我们整晚都站在鹿旁边。它会看向观众，审视每个人。你可以看到它的耳朵在动来动去。我们会抚摸它或抓抓它的脖子。
What did he do when they applauded? I would think that for an animal, that must have been so strange, the noise that would come from that.
当人们鼓掌时它做了什么？我觉得对一只动物来说，那一定很奇怪，那种发出的声音。
Nothing. He stood there. That's when he'd wiggle his tail and his ears would go back and forth.
什么也没做。它站在那儿。那是它会摇尾巴、耳朵动来动去的时候。
Now, your dad, who had been against bringing in a wild animal the whole time. You remember what his reaction was to the play?
那么，你爸爸，一直反对带野生动物回来。你记得他对这场戏的反应是什么吗？
I can remember him saying that it was really a nice play, and he was glad that the deer had a part in it. But I remember when we started to brand, we just begged dad to let us castrate him, and he wouldn't do it. And as a kid, I just-- oh, I was upset.
我记得他说那真是一场不错的戏，他很高兴那只鹿在里面有份。但我记得当我们开始打烙印时，我们恳求爸爸让我们给它去势，但他拒绝了。作为一个孩子，我——噢，我很沮丧。
Wait, why did you want your dad to castrate him.
等等，你们为什么想让你爸爸给它去势？
So he'd stay home. It's just like a dog. You take a dog, and if you've got a male dog, and you don't want that dog to go, I call it, tramping all over the countryside, you castrate him. We knew that if dad had let us castrate him, we would have had him forever. But no. So he wouldn't let us castrate him.
这样它就会待在家里。就像狗一样。如果你有一只公狗，你不想让这只狗，我称之为，在乡间四处乱跑，你就会给它去势。我们知道，如果爸爸让我们给它去势，我们就永远拥有它了。但不。所以他没让我们给它去势。
Over the next year, Bambi grew up, developed antlers. Connie and her sisters liked to touch the velvet on his antlers, she says. And Bambi started acting differently. Sometimes, he'd just wander away for days. And when hunting season rolled around, the girls begged their dad to lock up Bambi somewhere on their property. But their dad said, no, that wasn't right. And they didn't ask twice, she says.
在接下来的那一年里，Bambi长大了，长出了鹿角。Connie和她的姐妹喜欢触摸鹿角上的绒毛，她说。Bambi开始表现得不一样了。有时它会独自游荡几天。当狩猎季节到来时，女孩们恳求爸爸把Bambi关在他们财产里的某个地方。但爸爸说，那是不对的。她们不敢问第二次，她说。
Fortunately, because it was a small town, and especially after the Christmas play, everybody in the valley there knew about Bambi. The girls would take him into town sometimes in a car. And people would come up to them on the street and pet him. And they took special precautions during hunting season so everybody would recognize him.
幸运的是，因为是个小镇，特别是在那场圣诞剧之后，山谷里的每个人都知道Bambi。女孩们有时会用车把它带进城里。人们会在街上走过来抚摸它。他们在狩猎季节采取了特别的预防措施，以便每个人都能认出它。
We had a big red scarf on him. And then we had a sheep bell, which is just a little smaller than a cow bell. And we'd painted this sheep bell red. And then, of course, when fall come, you know, late fall, why, he took off. And about 10 miles away, some guy, I guess, they said-- I never did ever talk to the guy, but they said he drove right up to him and shot him.
我们给它系了一条大红围巾。然后有一个羊铃，比牛铃稍微小一点。我们把这个羊铃涂成了红色。然后，当然，秋天来的时候，晚秋，它就跑了。大约10英里外，有个家伙，我猜，他们说——我从未和那个家伙说过话，但他们说他直接开车过去就把它射杀了。
Oh, the deer didn't even run away.
噢，这只鹿甚至没有逃跑？
Oh, no. No, he wouldn't run. Because he was desensitized. He wasn't afraid of people.
噢，不。不，它不会跑。因为它已经脱敏了。它不怕人。
When the deer was killed, what did your dad say?
当鹿被杀的时候，你爸爸说了什么？
Just told us that that's just the way it was. And that's what we got for bringing him home. He told us then, he said, that's what happens when you mess with Mother Nature. So I guess if there's a moral to the story, you don't mess with something that's wild. You just leave it be.
只是告诉我们事情就是这样。这就是我们把它带回家的代价。他当时告诉我们说，这就是干预大自然所发生的事。所以我猜，如果这个故事有什么寓意的话，那就是不要去触碰野生的东西。就让它待在那儿。
Oh, really? Do you think your dad was right?
噢，真的吗？你觉得你爸爸是对的吗？
I think he was right. At the time, I didn't. But looking back on it now. I'm still pissed at that guy that shot him.
我觉得他是对的。当时我不觉得。但现在回想起来。我仍然对那个射杀它的人感到愤怒。
Because you're sure that he knew him?
因为你确定他认识它吗？
Oh, sure he did. He'd had to have known. Well, in fact, I heard that he did, that he knew. I hope he enjoyed eating him. The son of a bitch. You'd better edit that out.
噢，肯定认识。他一定知道。事实上，我听说他确实知道。我希望他吃它吃得很开心。那个狗娘养的。你最好把它剪掉。
No, I'd like to leave that in. Is that OK?
不，我想留着它。可以吗？
That's fine.
没关系。
OK.
好的。
No, that's fine.
不，没关系。
I just don't understand how he could shoot him knowing that he was your pet. Like he knew you guys, right?
我只是不明白他怎么能在知道它是你们宠物的情况下开枪。就像他认识你们一样，对吧？
Yeah. And you know, thinking back, I would imagine he was probably, what, 19 years old. Smart ass teenager is what he was. I can remember we cried. Mother cried. Dad was pissed. He thought that was pretty low for somebody to do that to an animal, especially when he knew that it was ours.
是的。而且你知道，回想起来，我想他可能，怎么说，19岁吧。是个聪明的十几岁混蛋。我记得我们哭了。妈妈哭了。爸爸气坏了。他觉得对一只动物做这种事真的很卑劣，尤其是当他知道那是我们的宠物时。
Did you blame yourselves?
你们责怪自己了吗？
Yes. I did. Yes. The end result would have probably been the same. But he probably would have lived. He'd have probably got another year or two before he'd have got shot.
是的。我责怪了。是的。最终的结果可能还是一样。但它本可能活下来的。它本可能多活一两年才会被射杀。
You mean, if you had left him with his mom?
你是说，如果你把它留在它妈妈身边？
Yeah. Oh, yeah.
是的。噢，是的。
It's funny. I thought that we were going to have a sweet little sentimental Christmas story here. But now I feel so sad.
真有趣。我本以为这会是一个温馨感人的圣诞故事。但现在我感到好难过。
Yeah, it did end up sad. And if I was you, and you was doing the story, I think maybe I'd kind of take a little liberty with it and not burden kids with what happened to him.
是的，最终它以悲伤结尾。如果我是你，你在做这个故事，我觉得也许我会稍微用点自由度，不让孩子们背负它后来发生了什么的压力。
Really? How would you want it to end?
真的吗？你希望它怎么结束？
Oh, like it was just a really nice play.
噢，就像这只是一场非常精彩的戏。
And not tell anything that happens afterwards?
不告诉后面发生任何事？
Yeah.
是的。
But then if you do that version of the story, then in the argument between you guys and your dad, you win, because everything works out happily ever after.
但如果你做那个版本的故事，那么你们和爸爸之间的争论中，你们赢了，因为一切都幸福地结束了。
Well, I think at Christmastime, maybe we should win.
嗯，我觉得在圣诞节，也许我们应该赢。
All right, well let's do take two. So after the play, what happened to the deer?
好吧，那让我们再来一遍。所以演出结束后，这只鹿怎么了？
Oh, we took him home. The play was always put on on Christmas Eve. So we went home. Because it would have been, like, 10 o'clock. And of course, Santa Claus was going to come. And we was all excited.
噢，我们把它带回家了。那场戏总是在平安夜上演。所以我们回家了。因为那时已经是10点了。当然，圣诞老人要来了。我们都很兴奋。
And so in this version of the story, you guys live happily ever after, right?
在这个版本的故事里，你们幸福地生活在一起了，对吧？
Yeah. Right. Yeah. And then I vividly remember the next morning after, we asked if we could bring him in. And Mother and Dad both said yes. So we put a lot of Christmas bows on him. And we let him stay in the house until he wandered into Mother's plants. And then he had to go out.
是的。对。是的。然后我清楚地记得第二天早上，我们问是否可以把它带进屋里。妈妈和爸爸都说好。所以我们在它身上系了很多圣诞蝴蝶结。我们让它待在屋子里，直到它游荡到妈妈的植物那里。然后它就得出去。
Connie Rex. She's celebrating Christmas at home this year. She lives on the ranch where she grew up outside Woodruff, Utah.
Connie Rex。她今年在家里过圣诞节。她住在犹他州Woodruff外她长大的牧场。
[MUSIC - "BAMBI" BY PRINCE]
[音乐 - 王子的 "BAMBI"]
Act Three, Piddler On the Roof. Right, our last story today of somebody trying to summon a great holiday into existence comes from Ron Carlson. A story about a man, his wife, Drew, his daughter, Elise, a sled, a tree, and horse manure. Here's Ron Carlson.
第三幕，屋顶上的小调。好的，今天我们最后一个关于某人试图召唤一个伟大节日的故事来自Ron Carlson。一个关于男人、他的妻子Drew、他的女儿Elise、一个雪橇、一棵树和马粪的故事。这是Ron Carlson。
The audio broadcast of this show included the short fiction story "The H Street Sledding Record" by Ron Carlson. Copyright  1984 by Ron Carlson. From his story collection A Kind of Flying: Selected Stories by Ron Carlson, published by W. W. Norton  Co. Originally published in McCall's. The story is not included in this transcript since Ron Carlson retains print rights.
本节目的音频广播包括了Ron Carlson的短篇小说《H街雪橇纪录》。版权归Ron Carlson所有，1984年。出自其故事集《一种飞行：Ron Carlson精选故事集》，由W.W. Norton & Co.出版。原载于《McCall's》。由于Ron Carlson保留印刷版权，故事未包含在此文字稿中。
Ron Carlson reading a short story-- it's fiction-- called "The H Street Sledding Record." It's from his short story collection, A Kind Of Flying , Selected Stories by Ron Carlson . It originally appeared in McCall's .
Ron Carlson朗读了一篇小说——它是虚构的——叫《H街雪橇纪录》。出自他的短篇故事集《一种飞行：Ron Carlson精选故事集》。它最初出现在《McCall's》杂志上。
[MUSIC - "MERRY CHRISTMAS, BABY" BY VERNON GARETT & SIR STAN & THE COUNTS]
[音乐 - VERNON GARETT & SIR STAN & THE COUNTS的 "MERRY CHRISTMAS, BABY"]
Our program is produced today by Brian Reed and Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Tarek Fouda. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes.
我们的节目今天由Brian Reed和Jonathan Menjivar制作，成员包括Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Sarah Koenig、Miki Meek、Lisa Pollak、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike。我们的资深制作人是Julie Snyder。Tarek Fouda协助制作。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的行政助理。Damien Graef和Rob Geddes提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, one of the most experienced programmers in public broadcasting. He knows the ingredients you need for any successful radio show. And of course, they are--
《美国生活》节目由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ的管理层对我们的节目由我们的老板，Torey Malatia先生监督，他是公共广播界经验最丰富的节目策划人之一。他知道任何成功广播节目所需的配方。当然，它们是——
Vegetables, a head of broccoli, an onion, and one of the bones from the original Rudolph.
蔬菜，一颗西兰花，一个洋葱，还有原始鲁道夫的一根骨头。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "MERRY CHRISTMAS, BABY" BY VERNON GARETT & SIR STAN & THE COUNTS]
[音乐 - VERNON GARETT & SIR STAN & THE COUNTS的 "MERRY CHRISTMAS, BABY"]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。